[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات
السعوديه والخليج اليكم العناوين
بعد الاتفاق السعودي الايراني الاتحاد
الاوروبي يامل باستقرار المنطقه وروسيا
تكشف عن ذويها في الحوار
[موسيقى]
قائد قوات فاجنري يؤكد ان القوات الروسيه
باتت على بعد نحو كيلو متر واحد من المركز
الاداري لباخ موت
وللمره الاولى السعوديه تحتفل بيوم العلم
رمزا وطنيا وتنظم فعاليات في مختلف مناطق
المملكه
في الرابعه ايضا
اكثر من 400 اربعين مليون زائر سيزور
مدينه الرياض اكثر من
الهيئه الملكيه للرياض تكشف للعربيه ان
استضافه اكسبو 2020 30 سيجلب اكثر من
اربعين مليون زائر الى السعوديه
السعوديه تودع الشتاء بموجه امطار رعديه
وانخفاض لافت في درجات الحراره
مساء الخير نبدا من ردود الفعل الدولي
المستمره على استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران في اخر
ردود الفعل رحب الاتحاد الاوروبي بالاتفاق
معربا عن تطلعه الى تنفيذه وقال الاتحاد
الاوروبي في بيان انه نظرا للدور الرئيسي
الذي تطلع به السعوديه وايران بالنسبه
لامن المنطقه فان استئناف العلاقات بين
البلدين يمكن ان يساهم في استقرار المنطقه
ككل
من جانبه اعرب مستشار الامن الوطني
السعودي الدكتور مساعد بن محمد العيبان عن
امل السعوديه في استمرار الحوار البناء مع
ايران وفقا للمرتكزات والاسس التي تضمنها
اتفاق او تضمنها اتفاق استئناف العلاقات
واشار مساعد بن محمد العيبان الى ان تطوير
العلاقات مع ايران ياتي من منطلق تمسك
المملكه بمبادئ حسن الجوار
القيادات دول الثلاث وتم خلالها مراجعه
مستفيضه لمسببات الخلافات والسبل الكفيله
لمعالجتها حيث خلصت المملكه على ان يكون
ذلك في اطار ما يجمع البلدين من روابط
اخويه وفتح صفحه جديده تقوم على الالتزام
بمبادئ ومقاصدي ميثاق غير الامر المتحده
ومنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
والمواثيق والاعراف الدوليه
رئيس مكتب لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه للجنه
المركزيه للحزب الشيوعي الصيني
قال من جانبهم ان اتفاق السعوديه وايران
ما هذا الطريق للسلام والاستقرار في الشرق
الاوسط
بعد خمسه ايام من الاتصالات الصريحه
والعميقه حققت السعوديه وايران نتيجه مهمه
فيما يتعلق بتحسين علاقاتهما الثنائي لقد
مهد تحسين العلاقات بين الجانبين الطريقه
للسلام والاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط وحل
النزاعات والخلافات من خلال الحوار
والتفاوض تدعم الصين دول الشرق الاوسط
لتعزيز الوحده والتعاون والتخلص من
التدخلات الخارجيه
بدوره قال امين المجلس الاعلى للامن
القومي الايراني علي شمخاني قال ان الصين
قدمت شروطا مواتيه للتوصل الى الاتفاقيه
مع السعوديه واكد شاروخان ان الصين ستلعب
باستمرار دورا مهما في تعزيز السلام
والاستقرار على الصعيدين الدولي والاقليمي
الصين قدمت شروط المواسيه للتوصل الى
الاتفاقيه هذا دليل حي على سياسات
والمفاهيم الاساسيه لدبلوماسيه الصين
والتي تتضمن المبادره الرئيسيه لبناء
مجتمع ومصير مشترك للبشريه ايران تدعم
بقوه المبادرات ذات الصله اعتقد وبقوه انه
في ظل توجيه السياسات والمفاهيم
الدبلوماسيه التي ذكرتها فان الصين ستلعب
باستمرار دورا مهما في تعزيز السلام
والاستقرار على الصعيدين الدولي والاقليمي
وفي مزيد من ردود الفعل على الاتفاق قال
نائب وزير
الخارجيهوف ان موسكو تهنئ الاصدقاء في
ايران والسعوديه والصين على التوصل الى
اتفاق عوده العلاقات واضاف بغدادوف ان
روسيا ساهمت في العمليات السياسيه والحوار
بين الرياض وطيران جنبا الى جنب مع دول
اخرى مثل سلطنه عمان والعراق
كما قال وزير الخارجيه الاماراتي الشيخ
عبد الله بن زايد ال نهيان في تغريده على
صفحته الرسميه في تويتر قال ان عوده
العلاقات بين السعوديه وايران خطوه هامه
للمنطقه نحو الاستقرار والازدهار
من جده ينضم الينا محمد الساعد كاتب صحفي
اهلا بك معنا سيد محمد
بدايه لنتحدث عن هذا الاتفاق وردود الفعل
التي تتوالى وتهنئ هذا الانجاز الدبلوماسي
الكبير بين السعوديه وايران متى برايك
سنلتمس ثمار هذه الخطوه
اولا هناك
حدث مفصلي في تاريخ المنطقه باكملها انا
اتحدث عن قوتين اقليميتين كبيرتين
السعوديه وايران وبالتالي هناك مسؤوليه
كبيره على عاتق المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في ان يكون هذا المكان من العالم
امن ومليء بالسلام والتنميه بعدما الحقيقه
عانى طوال العقود من الفشل ومن تردي اوضاع
اليوم الحروب وعدد كبير من اللاجئين
والقتلى والاحداث الدمويه اليوم الحقيقه
يعني الكل يتطلع الى جني ثمار هذا الاتفاق
المهم وانا وانا اعتقد والكثير يعتقد بان
على ايران ان تثبت الحقيقه جديتها وان
هناك خطوات كبيره يجب ان ان تتخطاها وان
تعدل من بعض المسارات المهمه واعتقد ان
الاتفاقيه نصت على مثل تلك الخطوات ولعل
اهمها الاتفاقيه الامنيه التي وقعت بين
المملكه وبين طهران في عام 2001 وسميت
باتفاقيه نايف روحاني اعتقد انها يمكن
البناء عليها
للحقيقه ان المنطقه تحتاج الى مزيد من
الامن والسلام تحتاج الى التوقف عن التدخل
في الشؤون الداخليه للدوله العربيه
الشروط الصينيه هي نسخه من الشروط
السعوديه وبالتالي هذه
ناولها الجانب الصيني للايرانيين
يعني ستكون يعني هي خارطه الطريق للوصول
الى يعني على الاقل علاقات حسن جوار بين
ضفتي الخليج العربي ان نتكلم عن قوتين
كبيرتين وجودتين على ضفتين العالم العربي
وشرق اسيا ايران الدوله الجاره ولا يمكن
اقتلاعها من جغرافيه المنطقه وكذلك الدول
العربيه يمكن اختراعها وبالتالي يجب على
الجميع الوصول الى تفاهمات تؤدي الى
اشاعه السلام والامن والاستقرار والبحث
الحقيقي عن تنميه اقتصاديه الشعوب تتطلع
في هذه المنطقه من العالم الى ان تتحول
دولها الى دول ناجحه هناك نماذج لهذه
الدول الناجحه ولا راس المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اعتقد ان الشعب الايراني يتطلع
الى هذه الاتفاقيه بامال كبيره لعلها
تنتساع التي يعني يعاني منها نعم سيد محمد
هناك الكثير من المحللين والمراقبين
يقولون بان هناك ربما ازمه ثقه بين
البلدين بالتالي ما خطوات اعاده بناء
الثقه بين البلدين لتحقيق هذه الاتفاقيه
والحصول على النتائج المرجوه منها
اعتقادها 60 يوم التي وضعت
ضمن شروط الاتفاقيه ستكون هي يعني الطريق
الذي يؤدي الى اثبات حسن النوايا والى ردم
الهوى بين ليس بين البلدين فقط وانما بين
ايران وبين بقيه العالم العالم يعني لديه
ازمه ثقه في ايران ولذلك اعتقد ان هناك
فرصه تاريخيه امام ايران للعبور من خلال
البوابه نحو العالم يعني الاستفاده من
المركز السعودي الكبير والمصداقيه
السعوديه السعوديه يعني لم تذهب نحو عقد
اتفاق سلام وعلاقات جوار متميزه مع ايران
الا بعدما وجدت ان هناك قبولا يعني لدى
العالم للوصول الى هذه الاتفاقيه السعوديه
تقود اليوم
الامن والاستقرار والتنميه في في المنطقه
وبالتالي عليها مسؤوليه تاريخيه تجاه ليس
شعبها وانما شعب المنطقه وهذا ما اكده
اسمه ولي العهد في احدى المنتديات عندما
قال انه يحلم بان تكون منطقه الشرق الاوسط
هي بديلا لاوروبا او هي اوروبا الجديده
بما تعنيه هذه الكلمه من اعمال وطموحات
واعتقد ان انخراط ايران في هذا المشروع
الشرق اوسطي الكبير الذي تقوده المملكه
سينعكس عليها وسينعكس على بقيه الدول
اليوم
نحن الحقيقه دفعنا خلال السنوات الماضيه
فواتير كبيره نتيجه فشل بعض الدول ونتيجه
التدخلات ونتيجه العمليات الارهابيه
ونتيجه حقيقه عدم الوقوف امام الخط
يعني الخط السياسي والوصول الى الى الى
التدخلات امنيه وعسكريه في بعض الدول
اعتقد ان اليوم يعني حاله الوقت لتوقفها
والتهاب نحو استشراف مستقبل اكثر نضجا
واكثر عقلانيه والانتقال من فكره الثوره
وفكره الايديولوجيا الى فكره الدوله وفكره
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه وحل الخلافات
بالتفاوض وليس بالعمل الارهابي او بالتدخل
في الشؤون الاخرى للدول المجاوره شكرا لك
من جده محمد الساعد كاتب صحفي
نشاه الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها
على مده ثلاثه قرون كيف تغيرت مراحل تطور
تصميم العلم السعودي سنرى
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد قال قائد مجموعه فاجنر
يفغيني بريكوجين ان القوات الروسيه على
مسافه 1.2 كلم من المنطقه الاداريه وسط
باخموت شرق اوكرانيا في المقابل اكد قائد
المجموعه الشرقيه للقوات الاوكرانيه في
بخموت اكد ضروره تعطيل القوات الروسيه في
بخموت وكسب الوقت للتحضير لهجوم مضاد
قريبا في السياق افادت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه في بيانها اليومي بان القوات
الروسيه تحرز تقدما في بخموت مشيره الى ان
هذا التقدم قد يؤدي لخسائر فادحه وقالت
الدفاع البريطانيه ان القوات ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تعاني من مضاد ضعف في خطوط
الامداد بسبب تسويق باخموت من الشمال
والجنوب
قالت وسائل اعلام ايرانيه ان طهران ابرمت
صفقه لشراء طائرات سوق 35 الروسيه وان
روسيا اعلنت استعدادها لبيعها هذه
الطائرات وذلك بعدما انتهت القيود
المفروضه على ايران في شراء اسلحه تقليديه
بموجب قرار الامم المتحده رقم 22 واحد
وثلاثين وتاتي هذه الصفقه بعد اتهامات
غربيه لطيران بتزويد موسكو بطائرات مسيره
في حربها على اوكرانيا
قال المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا عبد الله
بتيلي ان الاجسام التشريعيه المنتهيه
ولايتها هي السبب في عدم الاستقرار وحذر
بتيلي من ان اطاله امد الوضع الحالي في
ليبيا لن يؤدي الا الى استمرار الانهيار
وانعدام الامن
افترض انا رئيس المجلسي النواب والدوله
سيكونان من المرشحين الانتخابات النواب
والرئاسه الاجسام التشريعيه المنتهيه
ولايتها هي السبب في عدم الاستقرار الذي
يعرض مستقبل البلاد للخطر واطاله امد
الوضع الحالي في ليبيا لن يؤدي الا الى
استمرار الانهيار الاقتصادي والاضطرابات
السياسيه والاجتماعيه وانعدام الامن
اكد الجيش السوداني التزامه بمجريات
العمليه السياسيه وتقيد الصارم بالاتفاق
الايطالي المتحدث باسم الجيش العميد الركن
نبيل عبد الله قال ان مزايده البعض على
مواقف القوات المسلحه في محاولات التكسب
السياسي لن تنطلع على الشعب
تؤكد قواتكم المسلحه وقيادتها
التزامها التام بمجرات العمليه السياسيه
الجاريه
والتقيد الصارم والتام بما تم التوافق
عليه في الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يفضي الى
توحيد المنظومه العسكريه
وقيام حكومه بقياده مدنيه فيما تبقى من
المرحله الانتقاليه لحين قيام الانتخابات
بنهايتها شعبنا الابي
ان مزايده البعض بمواقف قواتنا المسلحه
وهي اول من بادر بالخروج من العمليه
السياسيه
والحديث عن عدم رغبه قيادتها في اكمال
مسيره التغيير والتحول الديمقراطي
في محاولات مكشوفه للتكسب السياسي
والاستعطاف
وعرقلت مسيره الانتقال
لن تطلع على فطنه الشعب
ووعي ثوار وثائرات وشباب بلادنا
اليوم وللمره الاولى في تاريخها تحتفل
السعوديه بيوم العلم والذي يصادف الحادي
عشر من مارس كل عام وذلك بالتزامن مع ذكرى
اقرار الملك عبد العزيز عام 1937 للعلم
بشكله الحالي وترمز دلالات العلم السعودي
التي امتدا لي ثلاثه قرون الى عده مرتكزات
وطنيه رئيسيه منها التوحيد والقوه والحكمه
وبمناسبه هذا اليوم يوم العلم السعودي
تشهد مختلف مناطق المملكه سلسله من
الفعاليات الثقافيه والفنيه والتاريخيه
الفعاليات ينظمها عدد من الجهات الحكوميه
منها وزارتي الثقافه والتعليم وهيئه بوابه
الدرعيه وتتضمن اقامه معرض العلم الذي
يروي حكايته الممتده على مده ثلاثه قرون
وفي منطقه الدرعيه نواه الدوله السعوديه
اطلقت الهيئه مبادره الدرعيه بيت العرضه
احتفاء بالموروث
العالم السعودي يعود لتاسيس الدوله
السعوديه الاولى عام
1727 اخضر اللون ويحمل شهادتين في الحادي
عشر من مارس عام
1937 اقر الملك عبد العزيز العالم السعودي
بشكله الحالي العلم السعودي يمتاز برفعه
لشهادتين ذات القيمه المحوريه للسعوديه
يشير السيف الى اظهار القوه والعدل يرمز
اللون الاخضر الى السلام والنماء في الاول
من مارس عام 23 صدر امر ملكي بتحديد يوم
الحادي عشر من مارس من كل عام ليكون يوما
خاصا بالعالم الوطني
ينضم الاناء من ساحه العدل في الرياض
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز اهلا بك معنا
نواف انقل لنا صور الصوره لديك يبدو بان
هناك تجمعات كبيره واحتفالات واحتفاء
وسعاده وفرحه بهذا اليوم
[موسيقى]
نعم فاطمه من ساحه العدل وامام قصر المصمك
احد ابرز معالم التراث السعودي هنا تحتفل
وزاره الثقافه السعوديه بيوم العلم الذي
تحتفل فيه لاول مره في تاريخ السعوديه بعد
الامر الملكي الذي صدر في بدايه هذا الشهر
بتخصيص يوم الحادي عشر من شهر مارس في كل
عام
لتخصيص هذا اليوم ليوم العلم والاحتفال
بهذا اليوم كمناسبه وطنيه كما نشاهد الان
في هذا المكان وامام قصر المصمك مباشره
فرق سعوديه فنيه تقدم الاغاني الوطنيه
الخاصه
بالوطن بالسعوديه
وبعلم السعوديه هنا في هذا المكان العديد
من الفعاليات تنظم
مدى ثلاثه ايام
متتاليه اعمال فنيه وايضا فرق استعراضيه
واماكن مخصصه لجميع الفئات خاصه مع تطوير
ساحه العدل وافتتاح محل التجاريه نشاهد
هذا الحضور الكبير على الرغم من ان
الاعمال لم تنتهي حتى الان وهي توشك على
الانتهاء ولكن نشاهد الزوار بداوا بالوصول
الى ساحه العدل
والاحتفال باليوم الوطني هنا ايضا نلاحظ
تواجد كبير للسياح الذين
يتواجدون في هذا المكان
ويشاهدون الاحتفالات بيوم العلم العديد
ايضا من الاعمال الفنيه المهمه متواجده
هنا على مدى ثلاثه ايام متتاليه ستكون هذه
الساحه متاحه للجميع
لمشاهده الاستعراضات والتعرف على تاريخ
العلم السعودي من خلال هذا المكان ايضا
يوجد معرض هنا يستعرض قصه العلم السعودي
بطريقه محاكاه مختلفه تعرف الزوار من
مختلف الفئات على العلم السعودي التغيرات
للعالم السعودي منذ 300 عام التغيرات في
الشكل ايضا دلالات العلم السعودي على
الرغم من التغيرات التي مر بها العلم
السعودي في الشكل الى ان الثوابت العلم لا
زالت باقيه منذ 300 عام سيتعلم الزوار هنا
وسيتعرفون اكثر على تاريخ هذا العالم
الفريد وهو العلم الوحيد الذي لا ينكس
وايضا العديد من البروتوكولات الهامه
للعلم السعودي هنا ايضا
عمل مهم
[موسيقى]
نحو 280 عاما مر على تشكيل اول علم
للسعوديه حتى وصل الى شكله الحالي في
يومنا هذا تلك الاعوام تخللتها خمس مراحل
رئيسيه نستعرضها معكم
[موسيقى]
معنى في الاستوديو الباحث التاريخي عدنان
الطريف اهلا بك السيد عدنان نحكي معك عن
العلم السعودي وليش خطير اليوم الحادي عشر
من مارس ليكون هو اليوم العالمي او اليوم
للعالم السعودي اهلا فيك حقيقه اختيار هذا
اليوم
هو اليوم الذي يقر فيه الملك عبد العزيز
طيب الله ثراه العلم بشكله الحالي في عام
1937 ميلادي في شهر مارس اقر العلم بشكل
الحالي ومن ذلك التاريخ اعتبر العلم
والعلم بشكل عام هو امتداد لما تم في
الدوله السعوديه الاولى والثانيه مرورا
بمراحل متعدد في عهد الملك عبد العزيز الى
ان اقر في ذلك التاريخ
مراحل تطور العالم اختار اختارت اسره ال
سعود العلم بلونه الاخضر منذ بدايتها
الاولى من على يد المؤسس الدوله السعوديه
الاولى الامام محمد بن سعود
رفعت الرايه في ذلك الزمان وبشكل مختصر
حتى ابناءه يذكر بعض المؤرخين من ضمنهم
المستشفى الاسباني علي باي العباسي
حينما زار مكه وشاهد 25 45 الف من الحجيج
من اتباع الامام سعود بن عبد العزيز بن
محمد بن سعود ومعهم الكثير من الرايات
داخل المشاعر المقدسه وحينما قرب من
الامام كتب وسجل امام الامام رايه لونها
اخضر خطي عليها كلمه التوحيد لا اله الا
الله محمد رسول الله استمر استخدام العلم
وحينما دخل الملك عبد العزيز الى الرياض
في 1902 استخدمت تقريبا نفس العلم بنفس
الشكل بنفس المواصفات الا انه انه يذكر
الريحاني في تاريخنا للملك عبد العزيز
حينما دخل الرياض الرايه التي كان يحملها
الجزء الذي يلي الساري لونه ابيض قطعه
قماش لونها اخضر خطه عليها
مشاهدتين ويعلوها سيفان متقاطعان ومن ثم
استبدلت الى ضم الملك عبد العزيز سيف واحد
من الذي خطى العالم السيد عبد العزيز
الخط العلم حقيقه في بدايات عهد الملك عبد
العزيز هناك من كثر من خط العالم ولكن من
الابرز السيد عمر عاصم الحسني من اهالي
الجمهور في مكه المكرمه انتقل تقريبا من
بدايه القرن الماضي 1990 ميلادي الى
الكويت
كلف بخط العالم السعودي وهو من اوائل
اوائل من خط العلم السعودي اضافه الى كونه
خط العلم الكويتي نعم
وفي مرحله متقدمه الملك عبد العزيز في عام
1926 ميلادي حين امر بانشاء دار القسوه في
مكه وعين الخطاط المشهور عبد الرحمن امين
عبد الله بخاري
وكلف ايضا اضافه لكتابه لايات القران
الكريم التي اذا هذا اليوم يعني تغطي كسوه
الكعبه كلف ايضا بكتابه العلم اضافه الى
كثير من العرب مخططين عرب قاموا بخط العلم
بخط الثلث انا حاولت يمكن من اجابتي هذه
استقيل انه انه كثير من الاخبار التي يعني
على الاقل يتم تناقلها انه انه خط العلم
الخمسين سنه او استبدل الخط موجود من عهد
الملك عبد العزيز من بدايته الاولى
وفي عهد الملك سعود والملك فيصل
يعني بقيه الملوك قد يحدث تغيير بسيط في
في انواع الخطوط في البدايه الاولى ولكن
كلها بخط الثلث ماذا عن تصميم العلم
تصميم العلم جميل السؤال للاسف كثير من
الناس يعني ينسب تصميم العالم الى شخصيه
المستشار عند الملك عبد العزيز المستشار
حافظ وهبه والمعلومه هذه غير دقيقه وغير
صحيحه يتم تناقلها حقيقه في كثير من
الاخبار والمواقع ولكن العلم كان هو
امتداد لما كان في الدوله السعوديه الاولى
والثانيه ولكن اللجنه الاستشاريه التي
كلفت من الملك عبد العزيز
تضم مستشارين
ومندوبين الملك عبد العزيز كلفهم بوضع شكل
العلم اضافه الى العمله السعودي العمله
المهم سيد عدنان يصير عندنا يوم نحتفل فيه
للعلم السعودي يعني ما الدلالات الرمزيه
لهذا العالم للعلم دلاله رمزيه حقيقه منذ
اختيار من بدايات الاولى للاسره الاسره ال
سعود
الاختيار اللون الاخضر هو من رياض الجنه
واختيار كلمه التوحيد هي الدفاع
او بيان لان لا اله الا الله وان خاتم
الانبياء الانبياء محمد
بن عبد الله اضافه الى نقطه جدا مهمه انه
انه العلم يرمز الى القوه والدفاع
والعدل والنماء والرخاء وجود السيف يمكن
في بدايه الاولى الدليل للقوه في بدايه
عمل الملك عبد العزيز في عمليه توحيد
المملكه دليل للقوه ولكن بعد ذلك بين انه
انه وضع السيف هو دليل للدفاع
وحمايه لشهادتين صحيح طيب يعني حكينا عن
الدلالات الرمزيه ولكن ايضا العلم السعودي
وباختيار كلمه التوحيد كما ذكرت سيد عدنان
انه جعل من العلم السعودي فريد يعني يختلف
عن اعلام العالم ممكن تحكيلنا اكثر عن هذه
النقطه تحديدا جميل اللائحه لائحه نظام
العالم في عام
1973 التي صدرت في عهد عفوا صدرت في عهد
الملك فيصل الطيب الله ثراه من 22 ماده
تناولت كثير من الامور المتعلقه بالعلم
منظم من ضمنها واهمها لا ينكس هذا العالم
وفي المقابل يمكن قد استذكر الروايه الشيخ
ابراهيم معمر السفير السعودي لدى المملكه
في العراق في عام 1933 ومع وفاه الملك
فيصل الاول ملك العراق اعلن الحداد في
العراق وانه تنكس جميع الاعلام الا انه
راى ان لا ينكس العلم السعودي طبعا لوجود
الشهادتين ما في شك لوجود الشهادتين كثير
من مواد النظام النظام الاساسي
للعلم اشارت الى نقاط جدا مهمه الا ينكس
العلم الا يلامس الماء الا يلامس الارض
الا يدخل فيه الاماكن الغير طاهره الا
يستخدم في مجال تجاري او في مجال الدعايه
الا يلف على الاكفان كثير من النقاط التي
فعلا جعلت من هذا العلم
لا حمايه قانونيه ومعترف فيها دوليا طيب
عدنان يعني من
دراستك وانغماسك في تاريخ العلم السعودي
ما افضل الطرق وربما انسب الطرق للاحتفال
بهذا اليوم العظيم بالنسبه للمواطن
والمقيم في السعوديه قد اكون اكثر السعداء
كون اعمل يعني وابحث في مجال تاريخ الرايه
من 36 سنه وجمعت تقريبا اكثر من سبعين
رايه من الدوله السعوديه الاولى والثانيه
وعند الملك عبد العزيز اضافه الى اعدادي
كتاب ضخم يتناول الرايه اكثر الفرحين بهذا
القرار الملكي في يوم العلم قد اكون انا
فعلا مهم جدا انه اليوم
يتعايش مع العالم وجود يوم علم قد يعطي
رسائل جدا هامه وقويه
للاحترام وذا قيمه العلم اكيد داخل
المملكه ذا قيمه ما في شيك مرتبط فينا
ارتباط وطيد ولكن النشر ان يتربوا عليهم
للعلم فعلا ان نستذكر هذا المناسبه بلا شك
انه تعديت للاحتفالات جدا
اخر نقطه مهمه جدا اذا تاذنين كثير من
الكثير من المواقع تتناول في هذه الايام
تحديدا ومع كل مناسبه في اليوم الوطني ان
العلم السعودي في بدايه الاولى كان يحمل
هلال وهذه المعلومه جدا مغلوطه يعني اتمنى
فعلا ان تعود الناس الى مصادر على الاقل
ذات ذات يعني بحث تاريخي شكرا لوجودك
معانا وشكرا لتصحيح هذه المعلومه الباحثه
التاريخي عدنان الطريف شكرا
لك نشره الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها
السعوديه اسرع الدول تحولا في تنوع
الاقتصاد تقرير لمجله فورب سيستعرض اكثر
10 شركات ابتكارا في المملكه
بعد الاتفاق السعودي الايراني الاتحاد
الاوروبي يامل باستقرار المنطقه وروسيا
تكشف عن دورها في الحوار
قائد قوات فاغنن يؤكد ان القوات الروسيه
باتت على بعد نحو كيلومتر واحد من المركز
الاداري لباخ موت
وللمره الاولى السعوديه تحتفل بيوم العالم
رمزا وطنيا وتنظم فعاليات في مختلف مناطق
المملكه
اكثر من 400 اربعين مليون زائر سيزور
مدينه الرياض اكثر الهيئه الملكيه للرياض
تكشف للعربيه ان استضافه اكسبو 2020
صار من اربعين مليون زائر الى السعوديه
حياكم الله من جديد في حديثه للعربيه كشف
فهد الرشيد الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه
الملكيه لمدينه الرياض كشفها ان استضافه
الرياض لاكسبو عشرين ثلاثين سيجذب اكثر من
اربعين مليون زائر معظمهم من سياح الخارج
ما يؤدي الى دعم السياحه والاقتصاد
السعودي طبعا تاثيرات كبيره جدا اولا اكثر
من 400 اربعين مليون زائر سيزور مدينه
الرياض اكثر من نصفهم سيكون من خارج
المملكه هذا سيدعم السياحه وايضا سيتعلمها
اقتصاديا قبل من خلال المشروع وتطوير
المطار وغيره وسيكون له اثر كبير على
المدى الطويل بسبب طبعا تعرف العالم
باجماع على مدينه الرياض وعلى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وزياده شركاتنا الدوليه
الرشيد اوضح ايضا للعربيه ان التصويت على
استضافه الرياض لاكسبو عشرين ثلاثين سيتم
في نوفمبر المقبل كما ان العاصمه تشهد
سلسله من المشاريع التطويريه التي تؤهلها
لاستضافه المعرض الدولي
اكسبو اليوم يشهد دعم غير مسبوق على مستوى
العالم من الدول الصديقه وشركائنا كل
انحاء العالم فالحمد لله الملف يسير بشكل
بشكل المطلوب لدينا طبعا
الجمعيه العموميه القادمه في يونيو من هذا
العام والتصويت في نوفمبر وباذن الله يكتب
لنا النجاح التطور غير مسبوق من ان كانت
مشاريع العملاقه مثل الرياضه الخضراء
ومشاريع النقل العام والمشاريع مثل صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه مثل الجديه والدرعيه
وغيرها في الرياض اليوم
هذا المحفل الكبير ولكن ايضا هذا جزء من
تطور مدينه الرياض تحت مظله رؤيه المملكه
اظهر تقرير نشرته مجله الاقتصاديه تقدم
السعوديه لتحل بين الدول الاسرع تحولا في
تنوع الاقتصاد واضافه قطاعات جديده وذلك
وذلك ما تقدمت خمسه عشر مرتبه ضمن قائمه
تصنيف مؤشر الابتكار العالمي لعام 2022
تقرير فوربز استعرض اكثر من عشر شركات
تعدل اكثر ابتكارا على المستوى المحلي
وصلت الضوء ايضا على اربعين شركه من بين
الاكثر تقدما على مستوى السعوديه اولها
شركه ارامكو بنحو الف براءه اختراع في
2022 وفي المرتبه الثانيه سابك ثم نيوم
معنا في الاستوديو الدكتور فواز العلمي
خبير في التجاره الدوليه اهلا بك معنا
دكتور في استديوهات العربيه في الرياض
دكتور كيف تمكنت السعوديه من تحقيق هذه
القفزه الاقتصاديه اولا مبروك علينا جميعا
يوم العلم السعودي
طبعا لا شك ان هذا جاء نتيجه حراك
وتنظيم للمؤسسات في جميع انحاء المملكه
لدى صدور رؤيه
2030 وكان من اهم اهدافها تخفيف الاعتماد
على النفط كسلعه وحيده للدخل
زياده توطين الوظائف وتمكين المراه وايضا
رفع مستوى النمو الاقتصادي
هذا الحراك بجملته ادى الى نتائج
رائعه في الواقع جميع المنظمات الدوليه
حاليا
تشهد بنجاح المملكه في الوقت الذي تواجه
فيه جميع دول العالم
التراجع التضخم الحروب
الدمويه الحروب التجاريه
سوء المناخ
وايضا زياده الديون السياديه التي وصلت
الى حوالي 300% من الناتج العالمي
الاجمالي
يعني الوضع الاقتصادي للسعوديه والناتج
المحلي المرتفع ولكن يعني نسبه تضخميه او
الضغوط التضخميه كيف تؤثر على الشركات
خصوصا انه ارتفع معدل التضخم في السعوديه
3.4% هو في الواقع 3.2 وهو من اقل معدلات
التضخم في العالم لان النمو الاقتصادي في
المملكه حقق ثمانيه وسبعه في العشره في
المئه مستوى النمو الاقتصادي وهو ارفع
واعلى نسبه نمو في مجموعه العشرين كان
المفروض ان تكون في المقدمه الهند
بسبعه فاصله ثلاثه من عشره ولكن المملكه
تخطت الهند واصبحت ثمانيه وفاصله سبعه من
عشره في المئه في سرعه النمو الاقتصادي
طبعا لاول مره في تاريخ المملكه الناتجه
الاجمالي
فاقه اربعه تريليون ريال سعودي وكنا نتحدث
عن تخفيف الاعتماد على النفط فاذا نظرنا
الى هذا الشعر نجد ان مساهمه القطاع
النفطي كان فقط 39 في المئه من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي بينما مساهمه القطاع غير
النفطي وصل الى 61% طيب والقطاع الغير
النفطي يعني الى ماذا يشير الارتفاع في
الاعمال غير النفطيه في السعوديه تحديد
الاقتران الخاص اولا
طبعا اهداف الرؤيه ان ترتفع نسبه مساهمه
القطاع الخاص في الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
الى 65% وصل حاليا الى حوالي 58% وايضا
التوظيف وتوطين الوظائف وتمكين المراه
تمكين المراه كان الهدف الوصول الى 30%
اليوم وصلنا الى 32% وتسعه من عشره
وهذا معناه تخطينا حتى الهدف في الرؤيه
اليوم في يومنا هذا طبعا هذا لا ياتي بدون
ما قامت به المملكه نفذت اكثر من 13
برنامجا تنمويا
قامت به
550 اصلاحا اقتصاديا
اليوم المستثمر عندما يريد ان يحصل على
سجل تجاري بدل ان يحصل عليه في خلال
اسابيع او ايام اليوم يستطيع الحصول على
السجل التجاري الكترونيا في خلال 180
ثانيه يعني ثلاثه دقائق وهذا
المعاملات الرقميه
والالكترونيه ولذلك حققت المملكه المرتبه
مراتب متقدمه جدا المرتبه الثانيه في
النواحي المعاملات الرقميه المرتبه
الثانيه في الامن السيبراني المرتبه
الثالثه في
الابتكار والعلم تحدثت على موضوع براءات
الاختراع المملكه حاليا حققت المرتبه 25
عالميا والاولى عربيا تحدثنا عن براءات
الاختراع عدد براءات الاختراع في المملكه
يعادل براءات الاختراع في جميع انحاء
العالم العربي
صحيح شكرا لك دكتور شكرا لك لانضمامك معنا
للاسف الوقت داهمنا الدكتور فواز العلمي
خبير في التجاره الدوليه
شهدت السعوديه اقبالا لافتا على عمليات
التجميل الجراحيه النساء تصدرنا النسبه
الاعلى في اجراء العمليات فيما تعتبر
عمليه شفط الدهون هي الاعلى اقبالا وتشهد
مراكز وعيادات التجميل تنافسا في توفير
التقنيات الاحدث في هذا المجال المزيد من
التفاصيل مع علي اللغبي
جراحه التجميل لم تعد للحالات الطارئه او
معالجه العيوب باتت ايقونه للجمال وضروره
للمظهر لدى بعض الرجال والسيدات ما جعل
عياداتي ومراكز التجميل تزداد وتزدهر
الاقبال بشكل كبير الايام هذه على جراحه
التجميل عندنا في السعوديه هو خارج
السعوديه لكن في السعوديه بشكل كبير هذا
يعود الى عدد الجراحين المهريين في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الحمد لله
والانظمه التي تسنها وزاره الصحه اضافه
الى نوعيه المواد المستخدمه الى التقنيات
الحديثه تجميل الانفيه وشد البطن وشفط
الدهون هي اكثر عمليات التجميل استهدافا
من الجنسين وتشكل السيدات النسبه الاعلى
في الاقبال عليها فيما ازداد مؤخرا التوجه
بشكل اكبر نحو عمليات تجميل الوجه
العمليات المستهدفه طبعا تختلف من مناطق
الى مناطق
لكن بشكل عام عندنا عمليات شفط الدهون هي
على اعلى شيء عندنا
عمليات الثانيه عمليات الشد بشكل عام
وعمليات الانف
فالاوانه الاخيره ازداد عدد عمليات شد
الوجه الاقبال هو على عمليات التجميل
الجراحيه ياتي بدافع تغيير نمط الحياه
ومواكبه صيحات التجميل وهو ما دفع حنين
الى اجراء عمليه شفط الدهون التي ترى
بانها ساهمت في تغيير حياتها وتحسين اسلوب
ثقافه التسوق لديها
كانت شد شفط البطن بالبدايه انا كنت مره
متخوفه من الموضوع بس بعد ما اجريت
العمليه كان احلى قرار تخطي بحياتي
الصراحه تغيرت نظره لنفسي بنفسي كمان
ثقافه في التسوق تغيرت انا بصراحه جبتي
اليوم لحتى اخذ استشاره بخصوص عمليات
التجميل للوجه كونه كتير من صاحباتي شفتهم
طبعا وعاملين كثير اجراءات
وشفت النتائج على وجوههم كثير حلوه
حابه ان اخذها التجربه هاي كنوع من
التغيير ما القيمه النفسيه او الاجتماعيه
التي تضيفها عمليات التجميل تساؤل اجاب
عليه البعض بان عمليات التجميل تعزز ثقه
بالنفس وترفع نسبه الاندماج في المجتمع
فيما يرى البعض الاخر انها غايه لا تستدعي
اللجوء لمثل تلك العمليات من الخبراء
للغبي العربيه
معنا في الاستوديو دكتوره تغريد الحمصي
استشاريه الجراحه وتجميل وحروق اهلا بك
معنا دكتوره هل بالفعل يعني من خبرتك 18
سنه في مجال التجميل دكتوره هل بالفعل
لاحظتي اقبال في الفتره الاخيره على
عمليات التجميل اول شيء ابغى اشكركم على
الاستضافه واقول لكم شكرا واهنيكم واهني
نفسي بيوم العالم اليوم المميز بالنسبه
للاقبال على جراحه التجميل الفتره بالذات
السنتين اللي فاتت او الثلاثه سنوات اللي
فاتت الاقبال زايد من النساء ومن الرجال
المراه بطبيعتها تحب الجمال وتبحث عن
الاشياء اللي هي تزيد من الجمال سواء
جراحيه او غير جراحيه طيب وما السبب برايك
على الاقبال على هذه العمليات ان كان من
النساء او الرجال وايش نوع العمليات اللي
يقبلوا عليها الطرفين السبب هو الوعي
التجميل صار موجود بدات الناس تقارن بين
التجميل داخل المملكه وخارج المملكه بدات
الناس تشوف مين الاطباء الكويسين ومين
الاطباء اللي مو كويسين بدات الناس تبحث
في وسائل السوشيال ميديا في الانترنت
الناس تقدر تدور على الاجراء تقدر تدور
على الطبيب تقدر تدور على الشيء الانسب
لها والافضل لشكلها طيب وهل بالفعل بحسب
التقرير يعني اللي شفناه سواء انه شفط
الدهون هي الاجراء الاكثر اقبال بالنسبه
للطرفين او الجنسين الرجل والمراه فعلا
الشفط الدهون هو الاكثر اقبالا لو نبغى
نشوف النساء بس فوق مثلا عمر معين بعد
الحمل والولادات عمليات شد البطن او تجميل
الثدي هي لتكون اكثر فيعتمد على الفئه
العمريه او اذا كان رجل او اذا كان مراه
ايش الاجراء الاكثر اللي بيطلبوه الناس
طيب بالنسبه للتقنيات الطبيه اللي موجوده
في عياداتنا التجميليه هنا في السعوديه
ماذا ينقصها لتصبح وجهه ربما عالميه في
التجميل ما ينقصنا شيء يعني احنا عندنا
الاطباء عندنا تجهيزات الطبيه عندنا
التعقيم عندنا كل الاشياء والسعوديه لو
تلاحظي في خلال السنه اللي فاتت تقريبا
بدينا احنا نسير وجهه او نصير لانه الناس
تجينا من خارج المملكه يعني انا شخصيا
عندي مريضات من مثلا دوله الامارات من
دوله الكويت من دوله قطر في ناس بيجوا من
الدول العربيه للمملكه لانهم عندهم ثقه
بالخدمه الطبيه المقدمه وبالاطباء اللي
بيقدموا الخدمه طيب بالنسبه للتكاليف يعني
في ناس يشتكون كثير من يعني انه تكاليف
الاجراءات التجميليه في السعوديه ربما
اعلى من غيرها لماذا علشان الجوده يعني لو
انا اسوي عمليه في مكان تكاليفه اقل شويه
حتكون جوده اقل شويه لكن لمن انا ابحث
ادور على الخيوط اللي هي جودتها عاليه على
الاجهزه اللي جودتها عاليه على التعقيم
اللي جوده عاليه على الطاقم الطبي سواء
تخدير سواء تمريض مدربين هذا حيكون يحتاج
الى تكاليف اعلى فحتكون هي التكاليف تمشي
مع الجوده اذا قللنا الجوده حنلاقي تكاليف
اقل لكن في حساب الجوده وفي ناس يتخوفوا
من الاجراءات العمليه دكتوره ربما حتى اذا
كانوا هم بحاجتها ايش تقولي لهم انا اقول
لهم زي اي حاجه في صحيه مخيفه بس اي خطوه
انا اسويها في حياتي اذا كنت مترتبه لها
ورتبت لها اقدر اسويها اما اذا انا غير
مرتبه ما اقدر اسويها زي سواقه السياره
انا اذا شفت السياره ما ربطت الحزام ما
سكت مع السرعه المزبوطه حسوي حادث لكن اذا
جهزت نفسي جهزت ربطت الحزام وسكت بشويش ما
حسوي حادث فنفس الحاجه انا اذا مثلا جاي
اسوي عمليه تجميل نزلت الوزن المناسب
ووقفت التدخين انتبهت للسكر او العلاجات
ما قبل العمليه وجهزت نفسي قبل العمليه
العمليه ان شاء الله حتكون سهله وما فيها
مشكله لكن التخوف لما انا اكون دخلت
العمليه بسرعه او من غير تجهيز هنا تحصل
المضاعفات او تحصل المشاكل كل شيء في
الحياه اذا رتبت له قبل يصير سهل شكرا لك
دكتوره تغريد الحمصيه استشاريه جراحه
وتجميل وحروق الانضمامك معنا اهلا وسهلا
اعلن المركز الوطني للارصاد في السعوديه
عن توقعاته لحاله الطقس في البلاد وجاءت
التوقعات بانخفاض في درجات الحراره على
اجزاء من الرياض والشرقيه والقصيم
بالاضافه الى احتماليه هطول امطار رعديه
مسبوقه برياح نشطه للاتربه على مناطق في
جنوب البلاد وشرقها مكه والرياض القصيم
وفقا لتوقعات مركز الارصاد السعودي
في ختام الرابعه نذكر بالعناوين بعض
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني الاتحاد
الاوروبي يامل باستقرار المنطقه وروسيا
تكشف عن دورها في الحوار
قائد قوات يؤكد ان القوات الروسيه تابعتت
على بعد نحو كيلومتر من المركز الاداري
لبخموت
والسعوديه تحتفل بيوم العالم رمزا وطنيا
وتنظم فعاليات في مختلف المناطق
الهيئه الملكيه للرياض تكشف للعربيه ان
استضافه اكسبو 2020 سيجلب اكثر من اربعين
مليون زائر
دمتم في امان الله
[موسيقى]